hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is the are you garbage podcast I am your
host H Foley sitting to my I don't know
meteorite
I'm 110 miles away from you what are you
talking about a [ __ ] idiot
and that's the way he likes it folks
Kevin James Ryan everybody give me a
nice big round hey what's up everybody
I'm happy to be in my kitchen right now
thanks for tuning in everybody we
appreciate it this is the first time
we're recording on this so hopefully it
works out where everybody's doing this
[ __ ] right man Korona times you get
a little bit of shittier of a product
that's what I'm happy about everybody is
recording digitally so bear with us
we're trying to I'm trying to find out
better solutions as well moving forward
so I'm happy to be here thanks for
thanks for tuning in very nice we
appreciate everybody rating reviewing
the podcast everybody sharing the
podcast everybody subscribing on YouTube
everybody subscribing on iTunes and we
have a very very special guest with us
today she's not only an amazing
podcaster you can see you're just about
everywhere she's also given us a little
bit of tips a little bit of advice and
I'm a very good friend to all you
garbage our good friend Tracy Cora now
so everybody nothing crazy just like a
daytime look fantastic I feel like
Michael Strahan and Kelly Ripa over here
they're doing this broadcast like this
how the [ __ ] is Michael Strahan he's on
Good Morning America nobody's on Good
Morning America yeah but he's not on
Kelly and Ryan because every single day
yeah that was a big to-do when he left
he just kind of rolled out and she was
he pulls the same thing on his wife
Kippy did he really yeah I meant some
flight attendant or somebody I think
that's why he's working so much talk
about garbage he's working to cover the
[ __ ] divorce cover the alimony
payment
he got he got crucified for that divorce
crucified now he's on [ __ ] 15 shows
he's a straight-up
Joey two-tone now yes yeah Joey Fatone
still operating talking about garbage
Network show and yeah I saw I saw Kelly
Ripa in the street she is I mean she is
Angelus that woman she yeah she's tiny
um I used to leave her and she had a
place right by me and I used to run into
her and town all the time and she's
probably around I would say 72 pounds
yes yeah she looks like she's smaller
than you would even think like yeah
thank you small man you see you're like
holy [ __ ] she's like [ __ ] she looks
evil behind the behind the curtain I
mean she's brutal I mean she's brutal to
the waiter I'll tell you that
she ain't she ain't cooled in a waiter
I'll tell you this between me you Tracy
and the lamppost I used to have quite a
crush on her back in the day when she
started with Regis I gotta be honest she
was your girl she was like your
celebrity crush oh my god I love that's
a weak sense trashing kepi yo that's a
weak celebrity right yo with the daytime
TV you ever see that one lady on General
Hospital ready to Regis so I got it I
gotta go to Tracey's house I I grew up
with rage I even use aspercreme because
aspercreme is Aspen free as we just
don't live where he died Regis I mean
question mark for you know the next few
months but right now he's good speaking
of which talking about garbage B instead
Kenny Rogers lost it well skate around
he's over the weekend I know it's so sad
I used to go to UM right on Queens
Boulevard in Queens
he had a Kenny Rogers Roasters well you
actually been the one I have I was very
we can stop the podcast right
penny Rogers roasters folks talking
about an unprecedented situation I
remember there being some kind of
cornbread oh I think there was I bet
Kenny made a mean cornbread I didn't
even know those were real this is the
first time I'm fine Tracy you're the
first you're telling me you've also been
there I had that I had I thought it was
just a bit this whole time I didn't know
no they they're very real so my two
grandmother's used to be best friends
and they were like pretty into roasted
chicken so yeah Rogers all day loved
them
and then you know we would stop in at a
I'm gonna date myself right now at a
Boston chicken good market yeah chicken
what a first came out as yes what's the
San Diego chicken put a fight up on them
more than just chicken yeah they were
just chicken when they opened the only
two things on the menu were just some
sides and then chicken or a chicken pot
pie and that was it that was that yeah
and listen I don't know especially in
New York a lot of fast food places in
New York are it looks like [ __ ]
downtown Beirut it's not a good scene
when you go in there but I mean they do
know their way around a chicken sandwich
in a Boston Market real chicken there
actually yeah yeah Boston Market is
awesome it's okay relax
I like their mashed potatoes um see I'm
not really into fast food whatsoever the
only thing that I really eat
that's like saying somewhere is pizza
like sales food pizza no like regular
pizza like I don't really eat fast food
at all yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't need
it that much anymore either
yes see I can students in our trash Here
I am i consider fast-food pizza would be
like dominos pizza my steez
yeah what you know a little season.we
your New York Italian I mean she's not
yeah New York Italian she's not eating
[ __ ] dominoes and you know and I
don't hear grandmother right now this
god I am garbage but I do not I don't
eat fast food at all Wow yeah I don't
either
oh he loves it oh dude I would eat fast
food man that's not good I mean I mean I
know I know how bad it is and I still do
it like I know you can feel it what it
does to your body after you eat it
speaking of which look at Mike look at
my quarantine [ __ ] acne it happens
and I never get pimples I got one here
one here one here you changing your
sheets Foley what do you mean your
pillowcases yeah of course of course of
course game changing over I have a
feeling that Tracy's like you know
definitely garbage doll she's got some
things that she's very you know kind of
funny we're in New York are you from
trace yeah let's get into it let's let's
let's start dropping this down I'm from
Forest Hills but I live in Kew Gardens
now which is about one mile away
holy [ __ ] you still live out there I
still do I mean I've lived other places
but this is where I've landed so you
grew up in New York City okay what kind
of I just a little bit of background
stuff here
what kind of all worked in your your mom
and dad do or or regrowth with though my
mom is a Catholic school kindergarten
teacher okay woman our community
was for 25 years and now she works in a
public school
yes my father he used to work for the
New York City Housing Authority as a
carpenter and he worked in the Queens
bridge projects he worked in the South
Bronx projects and he worked in
Ravenswood projects pretty good pretty
good
and what a who's from the who's from the
old country as they say so my father's
side of the family was closer to Italy
my mother's side of the family so this
is really fun because you know when you
get into ancestry DNA and I did that too
23 and me and my mother swore to God
that her mother was not Italian uh-huh
and guess what I turned up with my
results I'm 89% Sicilian we're kind of
Irish and I'm like hmm
Sicilian yeah they just send your
switchblade back in the mail I got I got
me and a clove of garlic
yeah results of the social club down in
Little Italy it's a yeah it says well my
my aunt so my grandma my grandfather's
sister she used to deal cards at the
social clubs and Little Italy there from
my father's family is from Little Italy
from like I think it was like Monroe
Street over there okay and that's where
she used to deal cards nice Lou's got a
little trashy yeah mostly it finds
Italians themselves you know it it's
like they try to they're kind of trashy
but they like there are those things
that they like real bougie with you know
me a lot of like you know a lot of
jewelry and stuff like that like the
flat yes very very very exactly gaudy
and that's the perfect it's like they're
here you got like the white Christmas
trees and [ __ ] yes very your dress is
supposed to be like a little wet
dress and you're supposed to have as
much lace and thrill on it as possible
yes
yeah we're a garter belt like minimize
that at my communion cuz I already knew
that I didn't want to be judged like we
don't have my mom you know she listened
for us so she doesn't have like a marble
statue in front of the house yeah sound
was a tiger or something
yeah like mom why can't we get like a
marry on the half-shell for the for the
garden yeah you wanted one yeah yeah I
did I cuz everyone in my class had all
your friends have one yeah that is some
that's kind of that's that is Italian
that's like New York great northeast
Italian garbage people know what that is
it's like it's like a statue of the
Virgin Mary in a little band show yeah
yeah of course
I don't like the touchdown symbol yeah
she's just they got a pick six I hear I
think I think people in Philly New York
yeah often know that like yes I've had
friends with this you know what I mean
yeah that's how you knew that it was
like a good house you're like Oh Mary
that's another that's a very New York
think that's a good house like that a
good that was a big thing with out with
like blue-collar trashing people back in
the day too was if they had a picture of
John F Kennedy hanging somewhere in the
house really oh just so you know trace
we're both Kevin we're both Irish
garbage no I know that I can tell from
my quarantine pimples safer for us if
you had you know most people like in
their car they would have like a prayer
card with like padre pio on it okay
we aliens okay yeah we always have seen
things yeah same assembly car yeah
hangin like on the visor looked like a
prayer card or something yeah yes but
JFK was huge because he was the first I
think the first Irish president of the
first Catholic president so he was like
our [ __ ] yeah you know first Irish
Catholic president ever the best
president oh yeah
that guy that guy was [ __ ] something
imagine of him and him and his brother
were around today they would have been
maybe busted 20 different ways to Sunday
they had been make Clinton look at your
school board yeah true alright let's
have some questions trace are you ready
to play
very nice kept you started off let's do
some of the you know some of the basic
ones
what lb be about being an old-school
Italian a lot of this is gonna be
alright because I grew up with a couple
of kids like that and there's no way
this is gonna fly with the factors no
there's no way you're gonna be garbage
on a lot of these I think especially the
basic questions you're just the right
questions if you don't think that I'm
garbage know what I'm saying it's a
different time yeah yeah yeah okay we'll
start with this what kind of smoke did
you have growing up my mother just like
a dove bar kind of girl and then when I
when the Dove Body Wash came out it was
big in the house a big body wash is a
step above dove bar but I tell you what
I bought at the grocery store but it was
still nice took a nice shower that's all
I use I use the pink dove bar yes my
grandmother used to use the pink I would
we use the white yeah that thing's great
awesome again yeah the grameen inside
grandma's always grandmom's always did
have pink stuff didn't they what was up
with that
that's the tile what grocery store did
you have grown up P food it's pretty
good naki foods nice there's one right
up the street that's key food is the
rich key foot is the nicer grocery story
in Astoria foods are privately owned
their franchises so who could go either
way
it could be hit or miss but I got my
first job would you do I worked at it I
worked at a grocery store too I was the
cashier I'm a girl there's no other job
that you could do
the grocery store when you're a girl uh
yeah it was kind of fun I used I
remember I worked there when ketchup
potato chips came out and we used to buy
a Magelang serum that's a fideya one
paper plastic there was no paper there
was no paper no paper dude nothing New
York is only plastic man you go out at
race you might not know you go out like
we grew up it's paper or plastic I'm
down I'm a jersey now and it's it's all
paper if there's plastics only New York
they give you 10,000 plastic bags when
you're late well now I mean in a while
and now that everyone's dying of you
know the plague they're letting us use
the regular plastic bags again but no we
didn't have a choice and I worked there
and then it turned into a CVS and I just
worked there it's like whatever you came
with the house I will do what I have to
do that's [ __ ] crazy usually they're
like doing construction you're there
like I'm just waiting for you to open
here dude you have to like take some
time off why they redid the place yeah I
am
I wasn't like I didn't go seamlessly
through them I worked a key food when I
was younger and then years later when it
became a CVS I was like oh right here I
know the building you know that's
probably good clothes on a Friday opened
up as a CVS yeah what's going on I'll
tell you what just to backtrack a little
bit
I love paper over plastic when you even
when you have one nice not too heavy
paper grocery store bag and you're
walking back to the house a little bit
of [ __ ] let us stick it at the top
you feel like you're in a movie yeah
yeah yeah all you have to do is when you
drop the corning have to drop the bag
and go Wow and then run over - yeah
exactly
it those bags movies always got thrown
on the ground when somebody all righty
Tracy
I think I could dig in here a little bit
you ready dig has ever been to a
gender-reveal party yes that's [ __ ]
I'm not going any one year old birthday
parties or Jeffy Kippy if you want to
get hurt you got to think about what the
Italians do think about communions I
know all right have you ever had a bar
laid out on the washer and dryer at
important family like if like they had
the washer and dryer next to each other
no my washer dryer was in the basement
oh that's tough yes sorry about that oh
okay what kind of alcohol to your
parents drink my father was sober and my
mother is like kind of just like not
good at drinking but like she'll like
have a sip of something once in a while
and her favorite is sambuca Oh the only
liquor that we ever had in the house
growing up we had like just a few
bottles it was it was gift you know it
was like and there were all cordials and
it was we had a bottle of Kahlua a
bottle of Frangelico and a bottle of my
parents were playing cards at my aunts
and uncles and they wanted to put
something in their coffee yeah there you
go
that's another old-school thing that
nobody does anymore always playing cards
you know playing cards or playing cards
over here I got wards door we're
quarantined but I'm just gonna play who
know yeah well you know what ruined it
you know what ruined it I don't know you
guys might be too young to remember this
but around like I don't know 2004 or
something like that I was alive then
okay so he's he's not 13 following
people I said I said you guys might be
too young to remember this
I realize I'm an old man people in my
generation started to like really play
poker yeah a poker poker there was a guy
who seems guy there was like 10 of them
there was a Doyle Brunson's like he had
the book and he would play the poker and
read the book yeah
the guys would walk around with their
own little like it's like the Silver
Haze is a championship [ __ ] loser
yeah you were running a Reve illegal
bookmaking operation in some kids base
who we talking about regular guys is was
me it was me and Tracey's me and
Tracey's cousins were doing me in my
aunt made merry no that's right cactus
or cacti
I have like five axes in my kitchen
right now it's a garbage thing some of
them as gifts yeah as gifts I no answer
for Christmas
yeah yeah the whole shelf of like
ceramic cacti - Tracy do you make God do
you make cookies around Christmas of
course I do I make cookies around every
day
look at me dude you did the pit cells
and all that yeah yeah we do them all
right I got one for you
are you a coke family or a Pepsi family
oh we don't drink soda we don't drink
our calories Jesus Christ
you don't drink soda no always amazing
people don't drink soda right so what I
said on what would you drink growing up
as a kid we would drink my mom would
make powdered iced tea like the last
track I grew up in liquid but order
Chinese food which almost never happened
but if we did they would give you the
can of coke yeah and
mother would let me and my brother split
it why is that with Jim people that grew
up in the city Chinese was like it was
like Halley's Comet you got it like
every four years my mom cooks every meal
she didn't believe in getting outside
food yeah that's I tell you what man
country time lemonade I when I was a
little kid I wanted to live wherever
they made those commercials so bad right
the kid riding his bike down the old
dirt road is feet off the pedals that
Hidden Valley Ranch I wanted to live in
Hidden Valley Ranch so bad the best one
clean-living those powdered iced teas
right he was like another one was like
four seasons or something was like
jorssy
foresee you were real trashy that's all
we had dude and it was the member that
were like who they were like two feet
tall and you would like to sweet dude oh
that was me too I remember the first
time you got that like big green pitcher
or the tan yeah yeah when your mom my
mom first let me make it you know like
when you got to the age where she's like
you make oh body the governor was all
but how about water we get in there and
it would turn into [ __ ] quikrete like
two seconds when when drops of water got
into the another really garbage thing we
would do with that we had our own
obstacle trees like you can make your
own popsicles and we would put the ice
tea we would make iced tea pot lemonade
a beer house the iced tea went first
lemonade if you were in a pinch lemonade
was always the last thing that would
happen with those ice-pops was you would
suck on them and they would just turn
into regular ice cube baby yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah we didn't get that Kevin did you
actually have the actual like popsicle
thing like the little because we used to
have to put it in the ice cube tray with
a toothpick like trash we weren't
[ __ ] hillbillies yeah my momma tore
the elastic tray yeah at the end so that
when it drips you could just drink the
drip I think so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
for sure
oh you're like that you're like rich
kids it got crazy we had to make our own
crazy straws right did you have a
grilled cheese maker growing up no my
mother made our own grilled cheeses yeah
that's anything was I had a lot of food
questions and that's not all yeah I mean
I forgot your mom was by hearted you
know she was I got a feeling Tracy's mom
probably knocks it out of the park and I
really dies but I gotta tell you as good
as my mom cooks I cook a little bit
better really now do you refer to do you
refer to it as a sauce or gravy I'm a
sauce girl
what does your mom call it my mom calls
it sauce my grandmother called a gravy
yeah the only gravy R is really only
like oh that's more Jersey now people
call it gravy you know my grandmother
called it gravy because see the thing is
and this is kind of the difference
between sauce and gravy
my grandmother would put like short ribs
in it she would put sausage in the sauce
meatballs and then it was gravy yeah
because it was like the drippings of the
meat into the sauce but like my mother
calls like like marinara sauce which is
just you know garlic and basil and
tomato oh well she caused that fast
sauce because it's like what I've heard
that before I've heard that before fast
oh I'm [ __ ] starving right now
all right moving right along here do you
know anybody that's double-jointed I
don't think so
cuz that was always remember the kid
video I can do that oh I can do that too
well that's it that's all we guys
that's nothing I'm talking about the kid
at the bus stop that can bend his arm
all the way back and a little ball with
he was always from a weird family
trash have you ever had any uncles or
relatives stay at your place until they
got back on their feet
what you think I would let somebody in
my house no I'm just saying like an eye
and also not now cause in who we look in
the basement yes I had my aunt lived in
when my brother moved out my aunt lived
in his bedroom and then my cousin used
to stay in the basement sometimes when
she yeah she worked in Queens because
she looked out very very far in Suffolk
she would come and stay for like you
know a few days days yeah stay in the
basement that's always a tough one I had
an uncle on the pull-out couch for like
three weeks and I was really really
cramping my style
oh that sucks man yeah there's a little
kid Tracy do you live do you have your
own place or you have roommates I have
my own place I live with my boyfriend
Laurie adamant about it's my place it's
my place so you're in there cooking all
the time
on Sundays that stuff's like that I cook
like crazy yeah I cook every meal like
now people are saying in the quarantine
like oh my god we have to cook every
meal and I'm like yeah I mean this is
literally what I've been doing my whole
life yeah yeah yeah it's easy I what
you're gonna poison me forever like not
just now what does your boyfriend do he
the comic okay okay I would ask you what
is it he'll do we know him
you know him we'll talk about it okay
yeah fine fair enough I don't put in
there of course this isn't [ __ ]
inside edition yeah this guy TMZ trying
to get our AC over is it Regis we need
some scandal for the numbers yeah
we're changing the format scandals and
animals trying to get the [ __ ]
ratings up how do you feel about cottage
cheese love it nice that's weird
2% hot style friendship only everything
nope 2% friendship is the brand-- 2%
style nothing else would you say hot
style hot style it's the large curd
I love the large curd big there's a
large curd Kippy
I'll tell you what happen with cottage
cheese so um I don't [ __ ] with break
stones because they have a ton of
additives and when you eat it it tastes
like glue
I love brick stones no I'm a big gorilla
glue God you see friendship and then one
day I ate friendship and it was not good
so I stopped eating cottage cheese all
together and then I found out that
friendship changed their recipe back to
take all the additives out and then I
was back on cottage cheese I'm getting
someone to store I can run chip pots
I'll that's it what about when there's a
little what about one friendship
sometimes puts a little bit of pineapple
or cherries in it I'm out I'm out no ok
how do you feel about skim milk that's
only milk I have in my house did you
have milk at dinner growing up no yeah
milk at dinner [ __ ] trash dude no I
know searching for somebody who else did
it though my mother was big on keeping
us away from dairy and we used to say in
the house dairy is scary would you grow
up in a [ __ ] because she was so
against us eating cheese or drinking
milk or she wait you can put parmesan
yeah Italian cheese doesn't count it's
Americans American was like yeah it was
like no cheddar it was like it was like
watch your cheese you don't want your
cholesterol to be high
that's hippy what do you got kids um do
any of your you know family members
cousins whatever extended family anybody
have a sport logo tattooed on them like
a giant's tattoo or a [ __ ] jet start
imagine should be a Jets fan but he
lives in Florida my brother lives in
Florida so I got a tattoo of Mayor
LaGuardia
it's worse than that he has on his got
the Belt Parkway on the side of his
finger he's got today I don't like that
to reflect upon me I'm not very close
with my brother
it doesn't matter wrong gene pool
accounts Wow
the Newport but the Newports wish yeah
oh yeah where's he live in Florida
he lives in Port st. Lucie okay Wow
that's [ __ ] side that and that might
be we've had a lot of tough answers on
this but yeah that's a new low here are
our garbage my cousin who obviously
doesn't talk to us anymore
her husband had the Fighting Irish guy
on oh that's big that's big with our
people we are yeah that's really trashy
bear this you got this guy or like you
know shamrock yeah yeah so you have any
family members that you don't speak to
anymore do I
I mean I talked to my mom and I talked
to my brother once in a while and Tracy
runs a tight [ __ ] [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
one way in one like my my cousins like
I've ran into them we don't talk to in
the stores like I ran into like my uncle
in Costco and they just like look at me
yeah I uh I know that I saw my dad in a
Wawa parking lot and we'd [ __ ] oh
jeez if that's not the most Philadelphia
trash thing in the [ __ ] world
I love it what is we [ __ ] each other
yeah it was like it looks like the Wawa
last week both had our hand on our phone
yes exactly to go yeah they're not
talking to family that's one thing that
we I said I feel like you're all borrow
money off each other y'all know me the
[ __ ] trash bag you look at them and
then you just Italian grandmother style
I think
I think the Folies are too scared of not
having anybody in the end so we know we
can never we can never cut anybody off
yeah it's a very family dynamic it's
like you you if once somebody gets cut
you go that's easy to do I'll just cut
them in them and once the scissors
around everybody can get it is it like a
big Christmas yeah no we have very small
holidays um the only people that come to
us rejoice everybody a lot of uncles and
fans over in fuzzles yeah that's good
uncles and fans yeah sighs its down
that's on the Boozer
I put the moves on a lot of fuzzums and
word denied but to move on some cousins
too
yeah that's always trashing when you're
like yes in my uncle not really my uncle
I don't know if a lot of people do that
anymore but like hey what's up uncle
Tommy and then you're like you haven't
seen me in 20 years
yeah it's Charlie explaining somebody
like Kippy member when I was trying to
explain my uncle's to you you were like
who's that your mom or dad you know
what's another kind of trashy I don't
know if it's trashy it's just weird
where if you call an aunt or uncle just
by their first a real aunt or uncle oh
yeah yeah yeah you're like hey Steve how
you and Nancy do and it's like whoa
buddy we would have got a spark for that
you would accept that that's a hittable
offense yeah see I had I had a lot of
cousins that were my parents age mmm so
they were they're like my aunt like I'll
say that's my uncle but I just call him
by his first name because he's not
really my own really your uncle but yeah
yeah yeah
well I definitely there's some of that
on my family my I have like two
half-brothers that are like could be the
you know you know my sister's kids age
you know it's right kind of dicey yeah
yeah
Tracy will you smacked as a kid did you
get hit No
Kippy no my brother did so I just told I
was like all right don't want I knew I
knew where the line was you know I
didn't know my parents were like
corporal punishment kind of people we
got smacked around pretty good let me
tell you something we deserved it every
single time now me and my brother used
to be the [ __ ] out of each other but
that's oh yeah yeah my my mom was a
single mom like somebody got divorced
and it was just me and my brother and my
sister in the house and that was [ __ ]
yeah he just spent hours on end it was
just lawless I mean granted I was
beating him up because he got a Nike uh
he got a Newport
Oh George how old was he he was seven
now imagine I just loved the cool hey
when you find your brain behind your
brand yeah he's a loyal guy yeah alright
quit being soft on the witness Kevin we
gotta go good find out what's up
alright what was your first concert
Billy Joel that's a great one [ __ ]
yeah you were a definite wait for 5
euros little as a little baby I think
that we like a monumental tour that tour
that was I don't know I don't remember I
know it was a stadium I don't know if it
was Shea Stadium or Yankee Stadium
it was probably so I'm 35 and would it
be 36 so it was probably around like in
the late 80s so maybe like 88 89
something like that
he was probably putting on all cylinders
- that's where we are big Billy Joel
yeah my dad loves a good a good six or a
Michelob one one while he was driving -
Wow Billy Joel Billy Joel late 80s
you're talking about the [ __ ]
innocent man tour
huh it was definitely before river of
dreams for sure yeah then you're talking
about the Christie Brinkley years and it
all went south what's the [ __ ] are you
drinking Kippy it's a Yeti do I have it
yet you want to see my Yeti
yeah Yeti up Foley go get your oh yeah
plug plug your podcast real quick as
well okay so I got Teen Mom trash talk
and then I have only in New York and I
have 90-day fiance trash talk awesome
I will I'm gonna do a bumper before the
episode some others as well for you I
love it yeah normally we would do this
in a much professional manner you know
you get to see uncle Hank in his in his
true element down there in the studio
all right because it is Rhoda
no you know I gotta tell you I'm very
grateful that we're not doing this in
the studio do you want to know why why
cuz you make it sick and I know I don't
care about that the angle that you put
the guests at is hurry up specifically
well we changed up it it is such an
unflattering angle that I was like I
don't know if I really have to diet
before I do this podcast well I'm glad
we did it this way too and then work
that perfect this is much better
did I look you look great you look
fantastic the makeup the daytime makeup
just like you know a little out for a
stroll very good thank you so much I
don't want to see the apartment what you
got what do you work with that day what
do you there's a lot of pillows let's
say that's always that's always a mark
of a classy broad got a lot of tools let
me get up nice I'm in the bedroom
because my boyfriend's working in the
living room so I'm not gonna hurt him
but you know that's a pretty big [ __ ]
place think so this is my bedroom
because I can't flip it I have a little
setup here that a king-size our queen is
that king-size yeah smoke a lot of
Newports in that bin yeah so it's your
place but he stays with you
[Applause]
and so that so that if the [ __ ] if
the [ __ ] comes to shove to the left to
the left right but I mean for years so
okay oh he's accused otherwise he's out
on the street and that's happened to me
before instead of at my girlfriend's
house one time and all my stuff was
neatly put in trash bags if you just
throw a trash bag that's one thing very
nice beautiful place thank you so much
we're not quite finished here yet oh I'm
excited a couple of questions have you
ever owned any of the following animals
who hermit crab yeah guinea pig yeah
lizard yeah snake no turtles now turtle
snake I got a I'm gonna be honest I've
had about six of these already and
finally a ferret or a hamster I had a
hamster happy he hadn't your instruction
I made my mom bring him to the vet they
put him on the same kind of amoxicillin
that we take the Bubblegum one along the
bubblegum oh my and it was a little
dropper of that and then I had rabbits I
had rabbits my whole life growing up we
had co-op outside the house my father
built this like apartment building for
them in the backyard
that's pretty good then that's pretty
good it was insulated and then you said
if you keeping your rabbit inside that's
no the rabbits shouldn't be inside did
he eat them at all no he's like red I
know I know it's not a you know like
it's talking living in the woods Italian
he was born here but yeah crazy old
Italians would definitely yeah Marty boo
Artie bucco shot a rabbit his backyard
all right I got one have you ever had a
birthday party at Chuck E Cheese
no what about McDonald's your own
birthday party I've been to a birthday
party McDonald's but I
never ever have allowed that yeah that's
tough
do you ever see the fights of
chuck-e-cheese that happen at like
birthday parties where the parents
getting like big fist fight for all zall
yeah I can't I chuck-e-cheese to me is a
stomach virus yeah it's not good I tried
to go to a Chuckie Cheese once as an
adult but they wouldn't let me in did
you go for the pizza I was going I
wanted to get para let me get their
pizza yeah they're like that I was
worried that there was nothing I like
sorry you know oh my god was gonna get
some pizza Billy's gonna be in here
without any kids also stop sitting in
the playground there's a Chucky Cheese
at this mall not too far from my house
and there's a Nike store next door and I
don't even like going to the Nike store
because the Chucky Cheese is near it
yeah I feel like I feel like even like
the the dinner with Chuck E Cheese is
greasy you know what I mean yeah like I
children get only kids it's an offensive
it's a bold statement yeah I'm saying
look at a picture of your kids really
cute but never make me meet it okay okay
good to know
got a hard a hard and fast line on kids
I like it cookie cut go go go go Tracy
do you have any Omaha Steaks in your
freezer no I wish no any delivered
states is [ __ ] but you always saved
the caller the cooler that's white
styrofoam cool I got a couple of those
things coming Andy yeah go into my mom's
garage is like going into a [ __ ]
garbage person Museum yeah exactly
exactly exactly
now this is you know I had a macaroni
and cheese I thought you guys had boxed
macaroni and cheese we do I've had like
five boxes so far this Gordon I'm
talking to her you idiot we used to do
the Kraft blue mac and cheese right the
blue box and wow i would swallow it it
was like swallowing fire for me for some
reason the crap
macaroni and cheese gives me heartburn
even when I was a kid that is the fire
of a thousand suns wow really
you know what crash the the blue box
isn't too bad that's middle-of-the-road
by a caronian cheese that's fine once in
a while we would get all beat up it fell
Venus that's real genius work that was
never a dinner food always for lunch and
never a dish which is weird it was never
a what it was never a side dish it was
always the main event always the main
event yeah we would have heard some
chicken nuggets from time to time too
would you skip I remember we were uh we
were a strict blue box Kraft macaroni
and cheese family and then my my dad got
remarried and I would go over his place
and my stepmom [ __ ] she dropped a box
of Velveeta on us do my head explode
dude I was like what the [ __ ] is this
year I was enriched dude hey pop you
gonna make a run of just brought around
something else the Velveeta oh thank you
so creamy I was thinking about that mix
it with water or anything it just could
the cheese's already so we were a big
Velveeta cheese a big clump you know and
then I jumped and then as I got older my
mom started buying an easy mac which you
would like microwave with the pallet
that was [ __ ] because he was like I
give this guy his mug is a blue box and
he chooses her yeah Tracy open it Tracy
have your vanilla have you ever been to
a wedding that had a cash bar
no ever been to a funeral that had to
catch more I've been to a funeral where
there was Spanish music okay drive by it
but there was like a boombox oh that's
tough yeah ah floor all right I think I
got one more okay we can you know lay in
this plane a little bit um all right one
more and this is again I don't know I I
didn't ask you to first because the
Italian the mother cooking but then you
said you were a blue box family so I
yeah how did the lunch that was a lunch
um any I mean obviously no wasn't a go
to but frozen pizza okay what would you
say what four lines was in for lunch it
was only lunch okay
today or when we were kids know when you
okay when you were kids
Ellie O's oh we have a winner
I love it Helios I still like it I'm
never gonna buy it or eat it but I still
like it but I do understand it's not
pizza
i-it's just illios also a good pizza
roll I'm not gonna throw it out of bed
yes Santino's are all right I'll tell
you this specially especially in the
quarantine right now there is levels for
the frozen pizza
elio somewhere in the middle you know
who reigns King undisputed French for no
question about it that [ __ ] DiGiorno
is all right now because that's like
that's like eating dominoes yes so fries
you DiGiorno's not what I want from a
frozen pizza a real the other hand give
me a tombstone all your jokes I mean
let's get organic over here some a me
some Trader Joe's
I hate Amy's pesto pizza yeah we you
gonna pesto frozen pizza like a jerk
down what are you doing trying to be
fancy yeah no you go classic you don't
find it that's your you're doing Alfredo
frozen pizza who do you think you are
that's true I like a nice supreme you
supreme san tres know-it-all I don't I
don't suck with pepperoni I don't eat
cured meats you only need I don't need
any pork except for AB reviewed and it
has to not be
goula get out okay and I don't I don't
eat pork besides that and I don't I
definitely don't need pepperoni yuck I
love a good slice Apep forget about
can't use something else she's a
complicated woman you are really very
device I like very um your [ __ ] pure
garbage or your like now I'm [ __ ] a
boozy ass [ __ ] and I want I have I'm
sitting on my bed I have 14 pillows
that's nice not decorative bed homeowner
king-size bed 14 pillow man but then I
see a brother with a newport that too so
who the [ __ ] knows I'll say this though
I think we've I think we've gotten our
first non garbage really yeah I'm saying
you're not garbage no we had we had
Jared freed wasn't garbage as well oh
I'd like to not say that oh okay I think
he's 100 percent sure I see what you're
saying yeah that's for sure so we're
saying Tracy is not garbage I don't
think yes very classy maybe one or two
garbage qualities but a classy a classy
dame nonetheless yeah that's so many
people it's great I love reality TV i
watch I'm a big 90-day fiance guy Big
Mike I know I gotta listen my wife I'm
dying my wife from another country we
had we had to do the whole from Germany
we had to do the whole they came on we
didn't do the Kalon now she we just got
married a couple of weeks ago to you so
we're going to were changing the status
of her visa because she was here
visiting so yeah but we did that we flew
back and forth four years for like five
four or five years is exciting
yeah well over there a couple of times
too yeah I think it pimple cream
the Germans make it strong yeah Tracy
thank you so much for joining us thank
LODs one more time sure I have 90 day
fiancé trash shaktimaan trash truck and
my brand new podcast
only in New York would host hemmed up
from Keith in the girl in Andrea Allen
from the hot best comedy hour and you
guys
on social media at trixie to Xenia on
Instagram and Twitter that's t RI Xie t
uzz ini and to get all that information
you can go to Tracy Krohn as Oh calm
cool I love it
Tracy you're killing it - your numbers
are through the roof you're doing all
this I'm so happy for you man appreciate
it we know you're doing us a favor here
great thank you so much for coming Kippy
what business you got that's it guys
just you know as always full video on on
YouTube so subscribe on YouTube were
please rate review on iTunes tell a
friend I think we're gonna be moving to
two days a week now that we're quickly
and you know we're just trying to get
some product out there during this this
crazy time we're in so I think we're
gonna be moving to two times a week nice
everybody hanging out there we love you
stay safe tell a friend you know
that's right social distancing two feet
apart